en la histórica pampa de la quinua
ayacucho donde perú y américa del sur
pusieron fin al dominio de españa en la
región el presidente pedro castillo
participó en el acto simbólico de
juramentación en el escenario en el que
perú en 1824 selló su independencia casi
o juró gobernar por un país sin
corrupción por los pueblos originarios y
por una nueva constitución luego un
grupo de indígenas realizó un ritual de
pago a la tierra quien lengua quechua de
los legendarios incas pidieron que la
tierra fortalezca pedro castillo y le
facilite tener una buena gestión
bastantes de tijeras que se remontan al
antiguo perú pusieron el marco colorido
a la ceremonia en este mismo lugar el
presidente pedro que ha sido tomó
juramento a guido bellido quien es el
nuevo primer ministro de este país
bellido es congresista por la región
cusco fue electo para el período 2021
2026 es militante de perú libre partido
de izquierda que llevó al poder a pedro
castillo el nuevo primer ministro de
perú viene siendo investigado por la
fiscalía desde el mes de mayo por
supuesta apología al terrorismo el caso
se remonta a la primera vuelta electoral
cuando guido ha vivido fuente
por un programa de televisión se le
acusa de haber defendido las acciones de
violencia del grupo armado sendero
luminoso por la justicia peruana castiga
el delito de apología al terrorismo con
una pena privativa de la libertad no
menor de cuatro años ni mayor de ocho
años el nombramiento de guido bellido
está generando cuestionamientos de
diversos sectores en especial del
congreso que no está de acuerdo con su
nombramiento